richard mander with uh a stafford gambit
question
uh so queenie two and stafford yeah
queenie two is actually like kind of an
annoying move
but it depends when they play it if they
play it here you can play um bishop c5
i assume you're referring to this
position
um i showed this maybe once before on
stream there's a funny trap
because usually white plays queen e2 to
push the pawn
and now white's losing after
this and then
if the f pawn moves we have this
this and then this so
it's a funny trap but okay if white
plays perfectly
like if white plays queen e2 and then
i'll move like c3
then it is probably objectively just
better for white not to say that black
still can
can fight you're probably gonna have to
play bishop b6 allow d4
and then try and poke and prod at the
center so the thing is like
the combination of queen e2 and c3 it's
not like so natural
so most players just don't know to do
this like it's not developing any of the
pieces
but it is kind of building up the
annoying center
um check with engine engine will
probably give like
1.5 for white yeah
um so in general if they play c3
preparing d4
the most flexible move you can play is
bishop e6
um i'm wondering why a computer is
giving castling
in d3 why not castling d4
okay it's probably just transposes but
this is still playable and there's still
traps that exist here
like you're actually threatening to take
now let's say g3 to develop the bishop
you take and you have rookie one
so white still has to like kind of ride
a fine line to to not fall
into any traps
um but of course of course there's other
moves
and we can dig into some lines like
bishop c5 and bishop g5 is natural
but then c5 is interesting it's it's
already getting
kind of complicated
oh oh thanks for charmander maybe also
known as tander
or tan tanner all these different words
ending with er
like this position i really wouldn't
mind
uh given that like only
two only this move and this move leads
to some advantage like e5 looks natural
here
the problem with e5 is white's not
actually threatening to take
because of the e file this is a common
theme whenever the queen goes to e2
especially lacking the bishop white's
going to be stuck with the setup for
for a while and while back's already
like much better here
um i'm sure a lot of people saw the
the hafu i still get asked about this
hafu david pakman game
um hafu played one of the best lines
with d3
and she just she like studied the line
like maybe 12 hours before she actually
played it
against david um but played c3 here
um and c3
is is probably one of the strongest
moves because it it aims for
uh d4 with tempo so the best response is
bishop
b6 which prevents d4
the d4 then we take the the pawn
and there's still some potential
i have a lot of challenges here so do
another random sub
playing phj 101 good luck
oh very meme meme worthy rating
1777. uh
i can't resist what am i studying these
days
um whatever i'm studying usually takes
place on stream
so yeah not not too much
um at least chess related
i've been listening to a lot of podcasts
recently got an audio book on meditation
another one on negotiating
so maybe some lesser chess content oh
okay opponent knows knows the hafu line
i showed this earlier i showed this as
like a good variation for white
so the move to play is vision b6
oh followers
i think follows followers challenged and
then didn't show up
i could uh can try and accept you next
white's being very safe
so this will be interesting we'll see
whoa is king
is this a mouse slip that was a mouse up
i'll give white the take back
okay
this looks fun actually don't know
so i usually have this position with the
bishop here and the
pawn on c2
but this should be good for for black
now especially after bishop dx g4
do i say negotiation podcast i'm an
audiobook
that's called never split the difference
i got like an audible subscription maybe
a couple years ago
i keep forgetting to cancel it i keep
getting credits every month
so i have to continually
just get new books if anyone has
audiobook recommendations please let me
know
let's play h2 first
and then
okay this looks very very close to
winning all i need to do is
checkmate the white king
i think the plan is to do this
maybe this we'll see what white does
also this
yeah the problem is white is always
having f3
so
it's not completely winning yet oh but i
could take here
wait a minute
i i should really think before i i start
clicking and dragging
so there's a bunch of candidate moves i
could take here i could play bishop here
i could play bishop here
and they all come with initiative
so if i play bishop g4 there's f3 this
move actually looks the most appealing
even though it forces rookie 1 which
defends the pawn
i was thinking then queen h7 threatening
bishop g2
but there's queen f3
oh there's a funny line so bishop here
here here
queen f3 i play i don't have bishop g4
let me maybe i just castle and then
later f5 and then this
let's go for that yeah white's never
going to be able to take this pawn
because then the h file is too dangerous
i see some people recommending books the
four agreements
something about nature
oh nerdski said he should challenge me i
have to be in like
very very good form to to play donya
he's so dangerous
um it'll happen at some point hi chasex
loving it tier two for three months
thanks so much
welcome back how's it going hope you're
doing well
i guess if you're a tier two sub you can
skip the line
if you want to challenge me i know some
people they just
they sub and then they they like to
watch
wait a minute oh bishop g2 is not a
threat
i was thinking it would be a threat but
not quite
okay so let's play f6 and then g5 like
g5 g4 actually looks really nice here
i am open for challenges people can use
the challenge command
you can connect your your thing with lee
chess
oh followers yeah i feel bad i should
give followers a game
but we have to get through this game
first is followers challenging me again
probably somewhere
what is the best game time for beginners
yeah ten minutes is probably a minimum
um also i'd recommend some increments
like ten plus 5 or 15 plus 10.
like if you're playing only chess i mean
trust.com also has a quick start games
but probably either this one or this one
would be the two recommendations
because anything quicker than just more
games are going to come down to time and
especially when you're first starting
out it's important to
get to basically get a feel of thinking
through things on your own
even daily chess like correspondence
chess
um which you can also do
on on the i chessnchest.com
is a good thing for beginners
um yeah like longer time controls like
30 minutes are also fine
sometimes it's just harder to find games
it can also take a while like if you
play a 30 minute game
then it takes an hour to finish one game
but then it's going to be a lot higher
quality than
any sort of like blitzer rapid game
okay so white sat sucked a little bit i
still want to do this move but it
doesn't work
and in the meantime white's actually
threatening to
oh to not trust the bishop
wait a minute what is this position
let's start with this keeping an eye on
the pawn
making sure there's no knife seven so if
takes takes a5 i have this move
because the pawn's pinned also thanks
for subbing
lol paul yeah so
the the pin is saving my bishop
oh he has a lot of pawns
we have seven pawns
okay i have five pawns
this pawn really wants to be more
relevant
if i could it would be better for me
just to take the pawn off the board
then have the open h file
there might be some plan like at some
point bishop here and then takes and
then
something something there's also some
plan of just winning on time
oh rating to 2600 challenge i got close
earlier
i got close in bullets got the rating to
i think high 2500s
debating what to do probably i'll
probably b5
like in general if you have a single
bishop left
it's better to put the pawns on light
squares so then the pawns control light
squares the bishop controls dark squares
you optimize square control
okay now white's actually threatening to
take the pawn
so it's the question do i want the
bishop here
or here neither square actually looks
appealing
i move here it's just stuck if i move
here there's e5
oh but there's this move wait counter
play
let's go for counter play
i made a yeah i made a kind of thought
process mistake
i was looking at like defensive moves
before considering forcing moves
this is just a made in one threat which
white defense
oh my time uh
this is confusing
let's take that
this is all about getting the queen away
from defending f3
which isn't so easy
hmm
what's going on
now i literally have all my pieces
but i'm scared of queen b7 so i'll play
this move
anytime i could trade queens
that's a free queen
it was not an easy position to play for
white
i was actually thinking there's a cool
line
uh instead of bishop b6 i can take on f2
i'll allow this and then just run with
the king
it looked really risky though
i might be losing the bishop
anyway good game ph so ph like played
one of the best lines
so this is an example of how even if
white knows up until this point
there's still some tricks i still
i still went for this idea um it was
actually kind of funny because king f1
might be objectively better
than castling because castling walks
into this idea
king f1 yeah king f1 is better than
castling
so that's a time where like it
it makes sense to give the opponent a
take back so they play a slightly worse
move